dort wird ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn vom kanton schwyz das schön und
kuprecht bei der svp und nationalrat
sind die anderen auch alle svp fdp und
cvp
irgendwie kommt mir vorstellen er
gelernt habe dass wir hatten einfach zu
viele namen zuviel kurze zeit und dann
der arbeitsstress thema tagtäglich hat
es sind etwas zu viel
das schweizer einbürgerungsverfahren ist
das strengste in ganz europa zwar gibt
es nur einen schweizer pass aber über
2000 wege in zu bekommen das entspricht
der anzahl gemeinden in unserem land zum
ersten mal haben kommunale behörden in
allen vier sprachregionen zutritt zu
ihren sehr vertraulichen anhörung
gewährt bei dem entscheidenden schritt
vor der kommission müssen die
bewerberinnen und bewerber ihres wissens
unter beweis stellen und zeigen dass sie
das räderwerk dass unser land antreibt
bis ins kleinste detail kennen
willkommen in der einbürgerungsfeier
willkommen bei fabrik des verschwitztes
la fabbrica die schwyzerin schweizer
machen
[Musik]
nach tagelangen büffeln ist der moment
der einbürgerungs prüfung für den
gebürtigen aus deutschen endlich da
andreas hätte sich nie träumen lassen
dass er mit 59 jahren noch einmal die
angst des schülers vor dem weißen blatt
durchstehen muss
[Musik]
so schätze damen und herren ich begrüße
sie ganz herzlich zum heutigen
prüfungsarbeiten sie bei nicht
selbständig höhere hefte oder auch noch
belegen sie die bitte auf die seite dann
verteidigte in freienbach im kanton
schwyz ist die bestandene prüfung
voraussetzung für das einreichen des
einbürgerungstests
andreas hat 75 minuten zeit um zu
bestehen
fällt er durch wird das verfahren
eingestellt
[Musik]
in lausanne wird kein schriftlicher test
verlangt die einbürgerung scoach ist
riesig und das bereiten die
bewerberinnen und bewerber auf die
kommunale anhörung vor ich möchte die
heutige stunde mit einem verweis auf
etwas aktuelles beginnen das heute nicht
nur hier in lausanne stattfindet sondern
in der ganzen schweiz
daher meine erste frage seit wann haben
die frauen im kanton waadt das
stimmrecht einmal wurden wir gefragt ob
ihr schweizermacher sein
wir haben nein gesagt wir seien bürger
macher wenn man so wirklich wissen ja
dass es in einer demokratie immer drei
gewalten gibt und diese drei gewalten
gibt es auf den stufen gemeinde kanton
und bund nur heißen sie jeweils anders
für das paar aus sri lanka ist es der
letzte kurs vor der anhörung
trotz all der besuchten stunden sind die
savanne sams verunsichert und brauchen
ermutigende worte haben sie die
unterlagen bekommen die ihnen geschickt
haben gut erklärt gut sie haben die
anhörung zu zweit beide zusammen
es müssen vorbereitet sein und man wird
sie fragen weshalb die schweizer werden
wollen
da probiert die erste frage lautet warum
wollen sich schweizer werden naja für
die frage gibt es keine standard antwort
das hängt von jedem einzelnen werdegang
weg geräumt um die 40 jahre die sie in
der schweiz leben haben sie so weit
gebracht
wenn sie gefragt warum muss dann wollen
sie wissen was machen sie dann nachher
was werden sie mit dem aus was macht
ohne mann aus unserem kurs hatte während
der anhörung ein blackout er ist
mittendrin aufgestanden und gegangen er
war so nervös dass er durchgefallen ist
[Musik]
seit der änderung des bundesgesetzes
muss die kommission in lausanne über
1600 hängigen gesuche abarbeiten
das dossier der sc bern ist eines davon
nach monatelanger vorbereitung
entscheiden die nächsten 20 minuten über
ihre staatszugehörigkeit guten tag
sie werden heute von einer delegation
der einbürgerungskommission angehört wir
gehören beide dem gemeinderat schon
lausanne an
bevor wir anfangen können sie mir in ein
zwei worten sagen weshalb sie dieses
einbürgerungsgesuch gestellt haben meine
kinder sind hier geboren
wir sind seit 2005 in der schweiz die
schweiz ist ein sehr sicheres land
meine kinder sind hier zur welt gekommen
und haben hier studiert
wir arbeiten seit 18 jahren
auch ich habe ein wenig zum schweizer
wohlstand beigetragen
gut ich sehe sie sind auf arbeitssuche
frau sie war nissan wo stehen sie den
moment ich suche eine neue stelle führen
sie schon bewerbungsgespräche
das ist nicht schlimm wie viele
bewerbungsgespräche bis jetzt also
treffen hat keines zu etwas geführt
ich suche etwas im verkauf ich habe
viele bewerbungen gemacht obwohl sie 19
jahre der schweiz leben bereiteten sie
wenn es ans das französisch immer noch
schwierigkeiten für ihre bisherigen
stellen braucht es keine großen
sprachkenntnisse jedoch sehr haben sie
vor 2018 eingereicht ob sie den
sprachtest bestehen würden den das neue
gesetz verlangt ist fraglich
die sprache hat ihren stellenwert aber
wir sehen dass sie klar kommen
im alltag können sie sich verständlich
machen dass seine eltern kamen in die
schweiz
sie sprechen weniger gut französisch als
ich ich bin ja hier geboren es liegt
wohl an meiner eigenen geschichte des
menschen die sprachlich mehr mühe haben
berühren
je nachdem auf wen sie treffen können
die bewerber also hoffen dass ihr
sprachniveau weniger stark ins gewicht
fällt als die stichhaltigkeit ihrer
antworten na dann können sie die flüsse
nennen die durch den kanton waadt
fließen welcher sehe ist der größte der
ganz auf schweizer boden liegen der
hatte er liegt ganz auf schweizer boden
er ist aber nicht der größte gibt es
nicht noch einen größeren hier ganz in
der nähe
sie waren so können sie die berge und
einige gipfel im kanton waadt
wir heißen die fünf grössten schweizer
städte von der broye bis le diable bis
jetzt schlagen sich die wanne sand sehr
gut
doch die anhörung ist noch längst nicht
vorbei
[Musik]
ich fange jeden tag sehr früheren und in
der regel sind es arbeitstag mit elf
zwölf stunden alle politik dazu kommen
die tage an denen ich mir neue rezepte
ausdenke für mich ist das adrenalin pur
es gibt so viel zu tun das ist extrem
intensiv aber ich weiß dass ich heute
abend zufrieden sein der uns genießen
kann
im engadiner hof spielt parolo eine
schlüsselrolle
wer einbürgerungs kandidat aus italien
ist seit über zehn jahren küchenchef des
drei sterne hauses
ich stehe seit 36 jahren ich habe meine
leidenschaft vertieft und konnte
karriere machen
ich habe alle stufen durchlaufen von der
küchenhilfe zum koch dann zu chef und
schließlich zum küchenchef zucker milch
und schnelles zur seite
das ist ein rezept nach portugiesischer
art ein rezept von mir kein kommilitone
dazu
während der hochsaison gleichen carolus
tage einen marathon auch bei seiner frau
anna ist es ein kampf gegen die uhr
sie und ihr team rasen von chanel zu
stellen
[Musik]
samstag schwarzen tag und alle abreise
ungefährt zwischen juni und 10 und 11
und die muss man alles auch wenn du dich
ohne cache in den fcb stunden muss alles
erledigt nach der geburt ihrer tochter
chiara hat anna eine eigene firma
gegründet um arbeit und familienleben
besser in einklang zu bringen
dank ihrer ausbildung im gastgewerbe
ließ der erfolg nicht lange auf sich
warten
sind auch aus portugal
vielleicht wurde schweizerische direkt
am lohn oder so ich werde zum kinde wo
das wo das macht was ich gerade dick ja
hallo ich brauche noch zehn minuten mit
dem heranwachsen ihrer tochter chiara in
den skiorten den sie langsam heimisch
wurden wuchs der wunsch bei anna und
polo den schweizer pass zu beantragen
das italienisch portugiesische paar
hatte das verfahren schon einmal vor
vier jahren eingeleitet immer richtung
harz organe fragt ja was ist los
ich musste operiert werden
aber nachts mit kaffee und alexander
sims grafik macht und er kennt
als ich gerade schock sie den moment das
wort krebs ist kein leichtes kein
einfaches wort
das ist ein inakzeptables machen
aber dank der unterstützung meiner
familie konnte ich es mit viel
optimismus an
barolo war nicht darauf gefasst den
prostatakrebs hat sein arzt bei einer
routinekontrolle festgestellt er konnte
erfolgreich operiert werden inzwischen
macht er alle sechs monate einen
bluttest
eine frau hat mir gerade mit der
krankheit zu leben
ich habe den krebs gesagt dass er mir
keine angst macht dass er verliert ich
gewinnen werde
im februar hat es immer noch schnee
unter wollten räume meine mutter kann
gestresst nach hause mein vater wollte
helfen aber er durfte nichts tun
wir hatten mühe ihn zu beruhigen er seit
den schnee draußen und konnte nichts
machen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jetzt hat die familie das
einbürgerungsverfahren wieder
aufgenommen wie in der ganzen schweiz
ist das gesetz auch in graubünden
eindeutig der schweizer werden will muss
für seinen unterhalt aufkommen können
ohne triftigen grund bekommt niemand der
finanzielle schwierigkeiten hat die
schweizer staatsbürgerschaft
das gilt insbesondere für
sozialhilfebezüger
die finanzielle situation jeder
kandidatin jedes kandidaten wird daher
bis ins letzte detail unter die lupe
genommen
an meiner arbeit gefällt ihr dass die
ganze technik und geld zur verfügung
steht kommt einer neuigkeit auf dem
markt sind wir die ersten die sie
einsetzen können ich schätze vor allem
meine kollegen als ich hier angefangen
habe haben sie mir viel geholfen
sie haben mir erklärt wie alles geht
wohin mit den sachen david der vor 13
jahren in die schweiz geflüchtet ist
bewirbt sich jetzt für die schweizer
staatsbürgerschaft
der eritreer wollte unbedingt gipser
werden dann musste er seine lehre aber
wegen einer allergie auf klebstoffe
abbrechen mit der unterstützung von sowa
und ev ließ sich damit zum verkäufer
umschulen
david hat nie sozialhilfe bezogen aber
sein umschulungs vertrag läuft demnächst
aus um sein gesuch nicht zu gefährden
hofft er auf eine festanstellung
sein chef kennt das prozedere bestens er
stammt ursprünglich aus pakistan und hat
sich vor einigen jahren einbürgern
lassen
den schriftlichen teil hast du schon
bestanden ja dann habe ich gemacht das
ist wichtig aber ich verstehe das nicht
ganz so besteht den test
warum stellt man die gemeinde noch all
die fragen es wird eher eine art
gespräch sein um sich kennenzulernen
sie werden dich bitten deine geschichte
zu erzählen deinen weg solche dinge halt
das ist in ordnung und dann werdet ihr
über deinen alltag reden was du jeden
tag machst dann arbeitet die familie die
kontakte zum umfeld
kurz gesagt geht da aber das kriegen wir
hin
in freienbach sind die kniffligen
prüfungsfragen trotz vorbereitungskurs
und tagelangem lernen eine
herausforderung für andreas wank mir am
anfang nicht gründung des kantons jura
war gast bei 71 dann fiel mir ein
bei frauen war ich also 79
bleibt noch eine deutsch ist meine
muttersprache ja für mich sehr schön
teilweise auch schwierig aber wenn man
dann erstmal noch deutsch lernen muss
und dass dann noch zu verstehen ja und
dann hat die die sinngemäßen
zusammenhänge
das ist schon also da hat mir früher ja
nicht so gedanken gemacht
da sind es schon schwierig
bis der teig und dabei
für die make ups steht die anhörung vor
der einbürgerungskommission kurz bevor
david hat alle hürden genommen und das
dossier zusammengestellt wie andreas hat
auch er die schulbank gedrückt und
stunden im tessiner swissness kurs
gebüffelt die unterlagen zu dem
anspruchsvollen test hat er alle
behalten
zuerst habe ich die geografie gelernt
ich wusste wo jeder kanton liegt könnte
alle straßenschilder alle warten alle
kantonshauptort bundeshalt tessiner
staatsrat meine größte angst war die
namen der ratsmitglieder nicht mehr zu
wissen
ich sah mir fotos an und dachte den da
kenne ich und weiß den namen bin aber
nicht sicher ob er es auch wirklich ist
bei der prüfung habe ich von 42 fragen
nur zwei falsch beantwortet mit einem
schweizer all die fragen stellst am
richtigen schweizer bin ich nicht sicher
ob er das alles um diese
einbürgerungskurse zu besuchen kommen
die kandidatinnen und kandidaten an
orten zusammen die meist etwas außerhalb
leben und nicht wirklich einladend sind
wie dieser hier mitten im
industriegebiet und legen wir den fokus
auf die gemeinde ebene die
einbürgerungswilligen besuchen einen
obligatorischen kurs der kostenpflichtig
ist und 40 stunden dauert zehn module á
vier stunden abends und am samstag
tagsüber früher haben die berufsschulen
und auch viele gemeinden kurse zur
vorbereitung auf die anhörungen vor den
kommunalen einbürgerungsbehörden
angeboten in der vergangenheit hat es
vereinzelt fehlentscheide gegeben wegen
der politischen haltung derjenigen die
die anhörung durchgeführt haben es gab
leute die je nach herkunft der bewerber
vorschlugen besucher zu genehmigen
beziehungsweise abzulesen
die zuständige behörde hat dann
entschieden einen kurs und eine prüfung
einzuführen
im bemühen möglichst objektiv zu sein
sie sind weder prüfung dar
haben sie ihre dokumente hier im tessin
befinden wir uns in einem kulturellen
und sozialen kontext in dem themen rund
um einbürgerung und migration heikel
sind auf gar keinen fall soll der
eindruck entstehen dass der schweizer
passt allen die ihn wollen einfach
geschenkt wird
der test dauert eine stunde die fragen
sind anspruchsvoll
wer durchfällt muss sechs monate warten
bevor er wieder antreten kann
für die kandidaten ist das eine
intensive prüfung
[Musik]
zu viele daten ich kann mir das nicht
mehr
in teil gesellschaft und wirtschaft
waren ganz komische fragen wie viel
kilometer autobahn gibt es im tessin wie
viele quadratmeter naturschutzgebiet
welche gegen der schweizer die höchste
bevölkerungsdichte
da musste ich wirklich überlegen das
konzept des referendums die
unterschriften und jetzt kann ich mich
nicht mehr die frage erinnern wie viele
personen haben 2016 sozialhilfe bezogen
wie viele nummernschilder prokop sind
eingelöst
wir sind in die schweiz gekommen um zu
arbeiten
wir hatten keine zeit um irgendetwas
anderes zu machen ich habe immer wie ein
verrückter gearbeitet
im tessin ist die hürde aus
obligatorischen test und
sprachkenntnissen für viele zu hoch über
die hälfte der eingebürgerten stammt aus
italien rezitierte menge 47 erwischt die
voraussetzungen um die schweizer
staatsbürgerschaft zu beantragen sind
wirklich sehr hoch sie sind viel
strenger als in all unseren
nachbarländern
[Musik]
adomat organisation ich halte das
einbürgerungsverfahren nicht für einen
höheren sieg
es stimmt wenn man die landessprache
nicht beherrscht
zum beispiel italienischen tessin kann
das schon hinderlich sein
aber wenn die sprache das problem ist
dann darf man sich schon fragen ob der
kandidat wirklich integriert ist
[Musik]
endlich ein sonntag zum entspannen für
ihn eher betrieb freizeit ist für den
hyperaktiven leger politiker
beim fischen bin ich weniger
patriotische nicht im ticino wahrlich
tessiner bin und im kanton tessin lebe
jeder fischer hat so seinen lieblings
fluss und ich mag diese gegend ja
einfach sehr
die schiene unser kanton ist bekannt für
seine carl patriotismus
wir werden den eindruck nicht los dass
wir auf bundesebene immer die letzten
sind die an die reihe kommen isoliert am
unteren ende des landes oft mit italien
gleichgesetzt wegen der sprache und der
mentalität ständig unter druck wegen der
grenze
das tessin gilt oft als sonderfall die
überzeugung eine unverstandene
minderheit zu sein
die nähert petrini seit über 25 jahren
mit der lega einer partei die sich bei
einbürgerungen für den
handlungsspielraum der gemeinden stark
macht wir werden oft als schweizermacher
betitelt aber man muss auch bedenken
dass in lugano allein letzte woche in
gemeinde jahr 72 gesuche bewilligt wurde
also schweizermacher ja aber wegen der
menge nicht weil wir den leuten den
schweizer pass schenken
[Musik]
im tessin ist die entscheidende die
kommunale ebene
das system ist anfechtbar denn man kann
das resultat positiv beeinflussen
je nachdem in welcher gemeinde man sein
gesuch einreicht und kommunen
in der schweiz kann jede gemeinde das
verfahren nach eigenem gutdünken
anpassen
fazit es gibt 2200 wege schweizer zu
werden ein regelrechtes dickicht die
gefahr der ungleichbehandlung ist fester
bestandteil des einbürgerung spa kurs
schweizweit betrachtet blitzt jede
fünfte person bei der anhörung ab in
lausanne entsprechend die zahlen dem
landesmittel
wie ist die schweiz politisch aufgebaut
die drei gewalt legislative exekutive
und judikative club gesehen sind das
neun feldern etwa so hier sehen sie die
legislative exekutive und judikative auf
stufe bund kanton und gemeinde kann sie
uns sagen was wir auf der stufe
legislative beim bund finden wie heißt
das gremium und wie viele mitglieder hat
es die initiative auf bundesebene das
eidgenössische parlament heißt
ständerat und nationalrat im
nationalrats indes 200 mitglieder im
ständerat zwei pro kanton die
halbkantone haben aber nur je eine
person insgesamt indes 46 total 246 in
der legislative dem parlament zusammen
ja die vereinigte bundesversammlung wir
passen unsere fragen immer an wenn wir
sehen dass ein kandidat mehr hat
korrigieren wir etwas nach unten
und wenn wir merken dass er sich
wohlfühlt versuchen wir etwas zu drücken
es gibt etwas bonus und nun zu ihnen die
kantonale legislative der staatsrat mit
sieben mitgliedern die präsidentin ist
frei moria geriet gut weiteres zu den
institutionen gut von uns aus ist die
anhörungen abgeschlossen
ich gebe frau heber landes wort nun wird
sich die einbürgerungskommission beraten
und dem gemeinderat eine empfehlung
abgeben
sie erhalten den entscheid der stadt in
vier bis sechs wochen per post bei einem
positiven entscheid müssen sie für den
verwaltungsaufwand mit mindestens
eineinhalb jahren rechnen bis sie den
schweizer pass erhalten für die sie wann
ist es bereits zeit sich zu
verabschieden
bei einem positiven entscheiden müssen
sie sich in geduld üben
in lusan braucht es zwei bis drei jahre
um schweizer zu werden
bei den drei themen tiefes fehlerfrei
ausgesuchten bei der sprache können wir
gut setzen was meinst du ja sie
verstehen alle frei ja und man ja stets
danach geht es nicht weiter naja
einsetzende genügend die
kommissionsmitglieder verfügen über
einen ermessensspielraum nicht immer
lassen sie bei den anhörungen nachsicht
walten
nicht nur ein typisches beispiel ein
student der hier geboren ist verpasst
die prüfer da habe ich dann wirst du
sagen nein
den lasse ich durch vor allem weil der
keine entschuldigung hat dass es heute
so gut lief verdankt das paar aus sri
lanka aufbricht und dallas und ihrem
vorbereitungskurs die beiden die selbst
auch eingebürgert wurden engagieren sich
seit jeher im bereich integration die
finanzierung der ahv
mein vater ist venezolaner meine mutter
stammt aus los angeles wie ich kam 1997
in die schweiz habe aber als jugendliche
ein paar jahre hier gelebt
und was passiert wenn einer in den
bundesrat gewählt wird caracas meine
nationalität venezolanischen
schweizerisch die leute fragen dann sage
ich ich stamme aus
so steht hoffmann idee schweizer werden
heißt nicht die eigenen wurzeln zu
verleugnen dass und brigit haben sich in
venezuela kennengelernt
dort des briefs 1985 auch schweizerin
geworden bis zu diesem zeitpunkt hat nur
männer das recht ihre
staatszugehörigkeit an die nachkommen
weiter zu geben
ich habe davon profitiert dass die
schweiz finden im laufe der zeit die
möglichkeit hatten ihre nationalität für
ihre kinder zu verlangen meine mutter
hat mich gefragt ob ich das will und
natürlich habe ich ja gesagt und so
bekam ich den schweizer pass in
venezuela
[Musik]
dank des roten pass ist konnten sie das
krisengebeutelte venezuela ende der 90er
jahre mit ihren drei kindern verlassen
in lausanne mussten sie bei null
anfangen ihre ingenieure abschlüsse
wurden in der schweiz nicht anerkannt
und da glas und die kinder mussten erst
mal französisch lernen für die
fünfköpfige familie mit ihren
bescheidenen einkünften war der weg
steinig das hat sie motiviert sich für
ausländerinnen und ausländer einzusetzen
[Musik]
wir mussten praktisch alles aus dem
stegreif lernen und als er dann mit der
vereinstätigkeit begonnen haben wollten
wir die leute scheinen zumindest die die
nach und scrum und ihnen bei dem ganzen
zu helfen
der prozess ist die beiden haben ihre
aufnahme in der schweiz sehr
unterschiedlich erlebt
[Musik]
ich hatte immer den eindruck die
schweizer seien ein wohlwollendes volk
wie das klingt vielleicht nach einem
kirche aber so empfinde ich das ich habe
einen anderen zugang
der schweizer ist einer der sich
beobachter wir werden die den ersten
schritt machen
er beobachtet die schalung ziemlich hart
aber du kannst sie knacken
wenn du sie geknackt hast kannst du rein
dann wirst du gut aufgenommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in freienbach scheint diese schale
besonders hart zu sein
selbst kommissionsmitglied annina
herrmann musste sich anpassen
als sie aus ihrer heimat graubünden nach
schmieds kam der pensionierten leitenden
pflegefachfrau glückte die integration
dank der familiengründung wichtig im
leben ich mir schon meine familie
endlich partner ich etwas machen dass
das was machen das glücklich sind
also konkret hatte das kloster war und
was ich im leben sondern bestimmtheit
und annina herrmann ist zutiefst mit der
schweiz verbunden auch als mitglied der
einbürgerungskommission findet sie dass
man sich diese postkarten idylle
verdienen muss
und dieses land machen sich prof
polizeiliches gerecht dass unter dem
strich gerecht
als freundliche menschen sind eigentlich
schon hauptargument
[Musik]
andreas wohnt zwar noch in der
familienwohnung hat aber neue
mitbewohner seine jüngste tochter lisa
hat der schweiz den rücken gekehrt
nachdem ihr einbürgerungsgesuch abgelegt
wurde
mittlerweile lebt der ganze rest der
familie wieder in deutschland die guten
nachrichten werden aus der ferne
übermittelt große tochter nicht entfernt
die wir jetzt am 17
besuchen sie wohnt in stuttgart das ist
kann hier aus näher als sylt vorher
wollte und meine kleine tochter die
fliegt viel
die arbeit ist kamin manager und es
dadurch auch ziemlich unabhängig
trotz einsamkeit und distanz hält
andreas am entschluss fest schweizer zu
werden
[Musik]
einige hundert meter entfernt beugt sich
prüfer roland jost mit kritischem blick
über die tests von andreas und den
anderen kandidaten
versicherung grundsätzlich hinterlassen
habe das ist alles korrekt geschrieben
um zu bestehen muss andreas zwei drittel
der fragen richtig beantworten was wir
in der zweiten säule versichert antwort
ist alter invalidität todesfall sommer
zur ergänzung der ersten säule und daher
ist die sicherung des lebensstandards
zusätzlich zur eigentlich richtig klasse
zumal so lässig wie im tessin hat auch
schritt einen kantonalen
einbürgerungstest eingeführt um das
risiko von willkür auf gemeinde ebene zu
unterbinden
wir dekorieren dass die frage was
schweiz betrifft geografie geschichte
das müssen optik wurde nicht die bürger
sprach war den frauen und die örtlichen
gegebenheiten prüft die integration ist
durch die integration nicht gemeint
[Musik]
in pontresina wird erfolgreiche
integration vor allem an der
erwerbsfähigkeit der bewerber und
bewerberinnen gemessen für bolt ist die
arbeit heilig den nationalfeiertag nutzt
er um seiner fantasie freien lauf zu
lassen
[Musik]
schon als kind konnte ich gut malen
zeichnen
mein traum war es schon eine kunst
schule zu besuchen
aber damals war die schule zu weit weg
von zu hause und uns fehlte das geld
deshalb habe ich mich nach einer schule
umgeschaut hin ich genauso starken
aktivieren könnte da bin ich auf die
kochschule gekommen
ich habe mir gesagt da geht es ja auch
um kunst und farben
heute abend spielen paule und seine
küchenbrigade die hauptrolle
so schweizerisch der nationalfeiertag
auch sein mag ohne ausländische
arbeitskraft dinger rein gar nichts
[Musik]
er steht für mich für emotionen
verhalten und verleite die in
feststimmung und den besonderen tag
feiern das novalis arbeitstag oder auf
jeden fall vorsieht womit du diesem
store hängt
da wäre schön wenn wir alle drei zimmer
sich und spaziert mit dem mund oder
picknicken
aber es gehört einfach dazu
ja jetzt werden
diesen erster august ist ein besonderer
tag für die italienisch portugiesisch
familie gerade haben sie erfahren dass
ihr dossier vom kanton bewilligt wurde
der nächste schritt ist die anhörung vor
der gemeinde durch thomas walther der
hotelier ist auch präsident der
bürgergemeinde pontresina
bürgergemeinden sind eine typisch
schweizerische eigenart eine art
parallel gewalt zur politischen gemeinde
[Gelächter]
also für die gemeindliche eigentlich
langzeitgedächtnis von recommind
vereinigung am herzen die
bürgergemeinden besitzen nach wie vor
viele grundstücke und auch wald der
bürgergemeinde pontresina gehört sogar
ein stück vom gletscher und die
bürgergemeinde hat das alleinige recht
zu entscheiden
der schweizer wird die bürgerversammlung
stimmt nicht etwa ab sondern nimmt die
einbürgerung entscheide des präsidenten
und seines rads zur kenntnis
mit beschrieben
denn hat sich frau silvia aulinger mit
ihrem so mittendrin
sie kennen sie sicher sich frau vom
langjährigen meister das wäre eine
biopsie
die positiven entscheide pro jahr kann
man hier an einer hand abzählen
wer sich in der kleinen berggemeinde
einbürgern lassen will entkommt der
sozialen kontrolle nicht den mitgliedern
der zuständigen kommission entgeht
nichts
wenn das beispiel graf warum gehen die
bürger ändert dringt mit den wert nicht
bewerten wir sagen das was sie wert sind
und dass diese verhandelbar sind die
schäden im 220 über eine prächtige
schlechten zeiten
grün ist zum glück sei der standort und
ein kleiner machen was er will wenn
meine die basis nicht hängt oder nach
der nicht leben will dann kann etwas zu
machen aber nicht mit mir passt also das
wird mir fehlen die worte
glaubt er dass die rote linie
überschritten ist zögert thomas walther
nichts seine macht geltend zu machen
auch auf die gefahr hin dass familien
dadurch entzweit werden
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich am nächsten tag ein
turnier habe und spiele kann ich nicht
schlafen
ich bin zu nervös sein leben wenn ich
dann auf dem feld stehen zählt nur noch
das spiel
elias kickt seit drei jahren beim fc
rapid logan sein vater davids lässt
keiner seiner spieler aus es freut mich
dass mein vater zu schauen kommt er ist
immer mit meiner leistung zufrieden
ich begrüße jedes mal während des spiels
integration das heißt ja nicht nur
arbeit sprache kultur integrieren kann
man sich auch über den sport unter
spielte gut
ich wünsche mir dass es auch in der
schule gut gehalten die kinder denken ja
oft nur an spielern ich möchte dass sie
in beiden erfolgreich sind
ich bin sehr stolz offen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
denn er weiß dass wir immer kämpfen ist
wir spielen immer gegen die großen also
jungs immer mit der ruhe bespielen
einfach weiter so gut wir können
[Applaus]
die jungs hatten es gut untereinander
sie finden sich gleich wert stärken
weniger stark blonde und schwarze
linksfüßer und rechts visa leute aus dem
einen land und leute aus einem handeln
ich bin der einzige der mit links
[Gelächter]
ich fühle mich mehr schweizer weil ich
hier geboren bin und es gar nicht kennen
[Musik]
könnte in die schweizer
nationalmannschaft
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh ja
ist der brief vom berufsbildungszentrum
von der prüfung
ich gehe mal aufmachen
prüfungsresultate
[Musik]
das freut uns in mitteilen zu können
dass sie die nötige anzahl punkte
erreicht und somit die prüfung mit
erfolg bestanden haben oh ja gucken ob
steht 49 55 punkte
besser als ich dachte es war sehr
entspannt da kann man sich auf die
anderen sachen jetzt vorbereiten endlich
erhält david das schreiben der stadt
sogar mit mir aber ja zur anhörung
eingeladen ist auch seine 14 jährige
tochter
[Musik]
du wirst zu ihren das wird klappen
ich weiß nicht so richtig angst in
lausanne machen sich di benedetto für
ihre anhörung parat
wir werden sie diesem termin sehen die
beiden mit sorgen entgegen
thomas walther hat familie corona
cardoso aufgeboten
die anhörung steht unmittelbar bevor vor
diesem wichtigen termin haben
anna und chiara die ruhige
zwischensaison genutzt und sind noch
einmal nach portugal gereist
[Musik]
andreas ist richtung deutschland
aufgebrochen er ist zum zweiten mal
großvater geworden und seine jüngste
tochter lisa wird vom albtraum erzählen
denn sie 2015 bei ihrer anhörung in
freienbach erlebt hat
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf